I mean touching you there I love
touching it let's let's do this the
three of us
[Applause]
I'm so relaxed I would but the sweater
is done to me out I'm Andy Williams why
would this bum you out
is it 1964 special you're doing Perry
Como why do you have to come down hard
on me
all right I won't do baby around listen
Jimmy your your funny guy and and I just
have a question for you which you always
seem to connect with a crowd if you're a
do you Jimmy part of the great Jimmy
Pardo ever have a hard time ever miss
with a crowd you just can't get them no
matter what you're doing now no never
okay next question what else you know
what not anymore you know I'm a
they're solid triples to home runs every
time now but sometimes it's a double and
I you get out to third baseball today
yeah but I did a gig in it's gotta be
late 80s Early 90s I've been doing this
way too long and I was at a naval base
and right outside of Chicago and I it
was my second time doing it and I was
glad to be back you know again I love
this country I'm a patriot I don't know
what you care about this country I love
it deluded at the end of my monologue
yeah yeah I was saluting America and
these good people
you can see a little flag in front of
you but like when you do that a little
salute you see go that's right that's
right could you ever be in the military
is that something you could ever do why
do you say that of course physically I'm
great a specimen
I'm patriotic I'm a bit lighter yeah I
think I got it all I don't know I could
never I was in the KISS Army for a
little while and I had to get out of
that I was willing to rock and roll all
night I was not willing to party every
day no no it's too much it's too much
I'm AWOL yeah yeah right now there's a
grown man 57 year old mattress like a
kitty cat roaming the streets looking
for me I hear him : can't come home
right now
so you never mess with a crowd I never
missed with a crowd this is a long story
by the way yeah this is like a six
minute long story right
certainly a six minute the long story
are you sure you want this one we get
the 30-second version there's no way
this thing think this thing pays off it
builds there's violence and if we if we
go to it there's not time this thing is
just gonna lay a turd we can't get it
this baby I'm telling it's dead wait
you're telling me not to ask you that
this story because all right door the
naval base you can't do that you cannot
do that you've destroyed it now you
can't ask this we already missed it now
I know and then you pretty much told us
if we go ahead with it it's liquid death
for everyone
that's what you say setting them up they
understand there's gonna be a nice
payoff here they've got a sign say
that's what I was trying to tell you cut
to that see that sign right there
can you see that sign right there it
says wrap
yeah if you want me to do it six-minute
story now we're gonna get into a six
minute story know where it goes back
that one of those stories it's like all
right it's gotta start fifty years if it
does is there I was on my way was nice
and read on I was listening to Toad the
Wet Sprocket and I was drugged every
reference you have made tonight is at
least 35 years so here's your assignment
pal we want you to wander around America
talk to some 18 year olds and find out
what what
[Applause]
you know what's trending this new show
Love Boat have you seen I'll fight these
people find love on a boat they get out
there they go out to sea and they follow
up sometimes they get the divorced or
something even at sea it's incredible
what did you bugger look at your posture
you're acting like you're Frank Sinatra
on this show let's do this and then
they'll be done no so I'm clear you're
talking about the new upstart Frank's
enough
[Applause]